pour tout de suite notre envoyé spécial
cyril payen cyril bonsoir où en sommes
nous sur le terrain
écouter pour corroborer les accusations
du gouvernement ukrainien sur le manque
de sérieux je dirais de c2c
cessez-le-feu et des corridors
humanitaires surtout dans certaines
villes sous pression pense à marioupol
kharkov
notamment eh bien nous étions avec
georgia ce bec cet après-midi dans le
front du nord ouest fief de kev pardon
dans les districts de dir pin au sommet
les bouches à écouter c'est exactement
la même chose qui s'est passé il y avait
des d'intenses combats des tirs
d'artillerie des tanks russes qui
étaient à environ un kilomètre de là on
se trouvait nous avons en fait
contourner par des villages le la voie
d'accès qui relie cette zone
résidentielle donc dire pin vers le
centre de kiev et qui est impossible
d'accès puisque le pont central le pont
principal pardon a été coupée pour
freiner l'avancée russe dont nous avons
contourné se parlent et les villages
environnants pour arriver dans la zone
dire pin ou là évidemment un convoi
humanitaire d'une centaine de bus ce
tentaient de se frayer un chemin pour
aller chercher ces milliers de familles
qui sont coincés dans ces combats depuis
trois jours et tenter de sortir c'est là
que évidemment on a construit en a
constaté ces tirs d'artillerie russe
très importante il y avait des fumées
noires qui s'échappe et un peu partout
et des bombardements intenses alors
évidemment concrètement sur le terrain
sur le front nord ouest de kiev là où on
se trouve c'est d'après midi le
cessez-le-feu le corridor humanitaire
n'a pas fonctionné et malheureusement
c'est une routine tragique un pour les
habitants de kiev et des environs
puisque ces derniers jours il y avait
déjà eu des annonces un de cessez-le-feu
et de corridors humanitaires et qui sait
sont traduits par une application avec
le même scénario c'est à dire qu'il faut
pense il faut croire
que les autorités militaires russes
laissent sortir les civils ukrainien
pour les attaquer audet qui sont dans
leur convoi pour sortir de leur de leur
résidence merci série l'acl payen donc
en direct de kiev